what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so as we get into Avengers vol 1
from Marvel now 2.0 but this deals a lot
with time in fact it deals entirely with
time and it actually deals with a
villain m'kay in the Conqueror and a lot
of fans love came to conquer I never
found him particularly interesting but
this story is written extremely well and
I absolutely loved the way it was done
by Mark Waid but before we get into this
what I want to do is I want to talk
about how time functions in Marvel
Comics so for the most part in Marvel
there's two different types of time
there's what's called linear time and
then there's what's called branch
universe theory now that sounds
confusing but it's not it's the simplest
thing to understand linear time is that
there is one single timeline and that's
it there's one universe one timeline and
that's all there is to it now what this
does is it creates something called a
paradox let's say for example that you
travel back into the past and met your
dad when your dad was a little kid and
then you did something stupid and you
got your dad killed well then the
question becomes if your dad died before
you were born then how could you have
been born in order to go back in time in
the first place
that's the issue with a linear time line
is that it creates paradoxes it creates
problems now Marvel could be saddled
with this but what Marvel does is they
use something called branch universe
theory so what Marvel will say is that
let's take like let's take the DC effect
let's take like earth one alright what
does the DC number let's say that right
now you watching this video right now
takes place in earth one alright and
you're like you know what I think I am
going to travel back in time because for
whatever reason you have time-travel
powers you say I am going to travel back
in time and I'm going to go see my dad
when he's a little kid
you get your dad killed well then the
question is how in the world did you
manage to travel back in time in order
to meet your dad if your dad had died
before you were born it those two things
don't add up it doesn't make any sense
and so what Marvel does is they say okay
because of the fact that you travel back
in time the instant you did that what it
did is it took the future that you came
from and put it into earth two it's now
a different universe and so what you did
is you traveled into the past and then
cross over to a different universe to
meet your dad for the first time and so
that's basically what they say that's
really what Marvel uses when it comes to
branch universe theory hopefully that's
pretty easy to understand it should be I
mean I don't really know how to explain
it any simpler than that but the idea
here is that with regards to Kang the
Conqueror what
establishes here really what Mark
Twain's doing and he's consolidating a
lot of things and the reason why is
because over the course of Marvel's
publication history came the conquerors
fought the Avengers the Fantastic Four
he's fought virtually everybody that's
really one of the reasons why a lot of
fans like him is because he's appeared
in almost every single story belonging
to anybody and he basically just uses
information and technology from the
future just run an absolute muck the
problem with this is that there are so
many different iterations of Kay in the
Conqueror no one ever bothered to
consolidate them and so you'd be
fighting came to Congress he came to
conquer they need to see scholar
Centurion and just like well it's a
bridge they came to conquer from
somewhere and that would be it that'd be
all you would get there would be no real
information given to us what Mark Waid
does here is well he doesn't necessarily
flesh out every version of came to
conquer what he does do is he
establishes where they come from and
what he says here is that each time came
the conquer traveled into the past and
fought the Fantastic Four it created a
new universe and in that new universe
came to conquer went on to become
somebody else that was every single
circumstance when he fought the x-men it
made a new universe when he fought
spider-man it made a new universe the
Avengers every single time he traveled
into the past he made a new universe now
within the realm of Marvel while there
are all these different versions of
became the Conqueror there's what's
called King crime and King crime is the
main guy and all he does is sit at the
very end of time you know when the
universe is about to be destroyed when
it's about to die whatever the case may
be but at the very end of time when
everything begins to come to a close
came to conquerors just sitting there
and all he's doing is feeding on all
this energy all these different
paradoxes that he's created whenever he
traveled back through time and so what
does origin story does is it tells us
how he got there and so what it what it
does is it picks up when King was a
young man this this main King was king
upon when he was a young man and what we
find out is that in the future that he
comes from time travel it's basically
forbidden Meo delving into time
investigating time it's all completely
forbidden and the reason why is because
if a person were to travel back and
forth through time not knowing what it
is they're doing they could cause all
kinds of problems and so because of this
came to conquer effectively broke the
rules used the information stored within
dr. Doom's time platform and began
investigating time the first trip he
took into the past came in
form of him making himself a pharaoh so
for those of you guys who are familiar
with the origin story of apocalypse this
is where that comes into play now his
motivation for traveling into the past
when the it when the apocalypse origin
first came out his motivation was rooted
and making apocalypse his heir what Mark
Waid does is Mark Waid comes along and
says that's the case to a degree but
came to conquer is also curious about
you know Egyptian legends of immortality
different things like that just wanting
to actually see what the past was like
the problem is that when he arrived in
the past and he had all this technology
the people viewed him as a god he became
overwhelmed with power and basically
became corrupted by it and began the
path of becoming a bad guy from here he
began just jumping around at different
points in time and what he began doing
was basically creating these different
caches of source what he would do is he
would go to like you know one planet or
something like that within the universe
and he would basically set it up so that
all that planet would do is manufacture
weapons for Cain the conqueror to use he
would go to another location and that
location would exist to do nothing more
than mind resources became the conqueror
could then turn around and use for
currency and so that's how he basically
you know kept himself going that's how
he kept his plans and mecha nations
constantly available to him was by
having a virtually endless source of
weapons and money and so eventually the
time came when Cain the Conqueror began
to realize that all the weapons he had
made came crumbling down all the
different minerals all the different
mines that he had made basically began
to disappear and what this indicates is
that someone is jumping around through
time and destroying all these things the
king the Conqueror made in the past and
so imagine that you basically traveled
to 20 years ago and then you created a
pencil you know and you set that pencil
on a desk or something like that
you travel 20 years into the future back
to the present day you look at the
pencil on that desk and then suddenly
that pencil vanishes the reason why is
because someone moved it as soon as you
put it there in the past that's really
what's happening here somebody's
screwing with the past to mess up Cain
the conquerors future and what we end up
finding out is that this is being done
by the Avengers themselves and in fact
it's not just the main Avengers it's
multiple eras of the Avengers the
original Avengers back in the 1960s the
second iteration of the Avengers in the
1970s and the modern-day Avengers and so
what this does is it now of course
allows us to kind of jump back to the
beginning of the story and makes sense
of
that's going on so hopefully I didn't
blow your minds too much I mean that's
really about as confusing as any of this
is going to get but if you have
questions feel free to post them on
there maybe some of you guys who are a
little unsure about what's going on but
essentially that the long and short of
everything I just told you is that the
Avengers are basically going throughout
the timestream and screwing up came the
conquerors future that's basically all
they're doing they're basically trying
to keep him from existing now the reason
why this is happening is actually not
because came at conquer is attacking the
Avengers but because the Avengers
initiated a conflict would came to
Concord specifically it was actually
vision who started it now the reason why
is because of the fact that in their
last encounter the vision began to go
through all these different scenarios on
why it is that came to conquer is the
way he is and what vision basically
realized is that there will come a point
when came to conquer will just be born
the choices that he will make the road
that he will follow will lead him to
becoming the villain that the Avengers
have faced off against time and time
again and so visions idea was to
basically alter the future by taking the
baby away from the road that it would
have been on and so vision literally
kidnapped became the conqueror as a kid
whisked it away to some place in time
that we have no idea where it is in
hopes that that child would grow up to
become someone other than came to
conquer and so because of this these
changes are still taking place these
changes are still still more or less
happening and so because of that these
versions of Caine have not necessarily
been affected yet and the reason why is
because of the fact that if you saw my
video on Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four one of the things that he
established was that if you go into the
past and you change something the change
is not immediate instead it's like a
wave making its way through time it
takes time to get to the person that is
supposed to affect and so it's not like
you would go back and shoot King as a
kid and then he was suddenly just
vanished what it would do is it would
take time the ripple effect would have
to get to King sometimes it would take
minutes sometimes it would take days or
hours or ever the case may be because
we're messing with the concept of time
and everything is sort of relative but
at this moment right now the way the
story is written these changes have not
affect Cain the Conqueror yet in the
extreme instead what's happening is the
Avengers are basically fighting off a
multitude of Kings different versions so
like Scarlett Centurion you know one
version of came to conquer different
things like that now the Avengers are
able to hold their own to a degree I
mean they're able to do pretty well
basically fighting against two versus
came to conquer the issue is that one of
these versions of khang basically begins
to interrogate division the reason why
is because they're both aware of the
fact the division was the one who stole
King when he was a baby and moved him to
a different location and so because of
this their question is where did you
take him because if this wave of change
gets to us before things are set back to
the way they're supposed to be then
these versions of King will simply cease
to exist so this story is quite
literally a race against time now
because of the fact that they basically
delve into the mind of vision only to
find that vision had basically dumped
his memory of where it is it he put this
kid to basically made himself forget the
idea here is for these different
versions of quema Conqueror to exert
from vision in the present to basically
manipulate the time stream to travel
backwards in time and look at everything
that the vision did and were to find out
where he put this baby so it's actually
a really simple and a really smart
maneuver and it works pretty well the
downside of the way that Mark Waid
writes this if he does it in a really
confusing way he really writes in a way
that that's a lot more complicated than
it needs to be but that's essentially
what this is that's really why I'm kind
of trying to simplify it as best I can
because it could have been a lot simpler
the other half of this equation is that
in Kings mind while they're basically
trying to track down the baby what they
realize is the Avengers are going to try
to step in and stop them every step of
the way and so what happened is came to
conquer actually begins going back in
time and essentially going to Peter
Parker going to Jane Foster going to Sam
Wilson the moment that they're born when
they're babies and begins the process of
killing them all off in order to make
sure that they never become Avengers in
the first place they're by never
challenging came to conquer in the
current day and so because of this you
know while this wave of change begins to
approach the Avengers and begins to wipe
them out they're all essentially whisked
away and what we end up finding out here
is that the reason why they were whisked
away is because they were sent to a
place called limbo now Mark Waid uses
the phrase limbo with a grain of salt
and the reason why is because in my war
comics there is an actual dimension
called limbo there is an actual place
but it's not a place outside of all
space and taun I mean it kind of is but
it kind of isn't what Mark Waid is doing
here is he's basically saying when he
says limbo all he's really saying is
that somebody took the Avengers out of
all space and time and so what this
means is that if they were to go back to
the universe if they were to go back to
the
Marwin universe then they would suddenly
vanish and the reason why is because
that wave of change would overcome them
and because they were killed as infants
they would simply cease to exist and so
again if we basically end up finding out
here that the person that moved them out
of this universe that moved them away
was actually a version of came to
conquer himself who exists outside of
all space and time so that's why things
get really really crazy with this story
it's great and it's really good but it
can really be mind-blowing and in some
ways that's why I say Mark Waid his
writing style is a little complicated
now with regards to this wave of change
that's going through the only person
who's not affected is Hercules and the
reason why is because no one knows when
Hercules was born or where he was simply
just there one day and so came the
conquer didn't have the ability to go
into the past and kill Hercules as a
baby because he didn't know when when he
was supposed to go he didn't know where
you were supposed to go what year
Hercules was born or anything like that
and so there's there was really no way
he could stop this and so what is up
happening if he actually contacts a
woman named Sybil now this is a cool
thing because remember in Marvel Comics
you have Greek gods you have Greek
goddesses they're similar but a little
bit different to what DC does with
Wonder Woman Sybil is basically an
Oracle a person that can see the future
and so because of this some Sybil
actually gives Hercules an artifact that
allows him to stay anchored to the
present so that they can kind of jump
back and forth through time without
getting lost in time itself what we also
end up finding out is that where this
baby king was sent was actually to a
place it was a temple in Vietnam that
belongs to the priests of Pama now the
priests of Pama are a group in Marvel
Comics that have existed for quite some
time whether by nature a pacifist race
and the reason why is because of the
fact that during the days of you know
the Korean Scrolls and they were whole
warring faction and all I kind of get
stuff where they fought for you know
millennia and millennia winded up
happening is the priests of Hama
actually vacated that entire territory
and began going in two by twos to
different planets and then basically you
know appropriating and expanding their
own group but some of them actually
arrived on earth and it basically
existed in shadow for countless years
now they've been around for a long time
I really want to say since like 1974 but
they've been used sparingly and it's
really just a way for Markway to invoke
an extremely obscure group and bring
them into the equation but the fact
remains here with Hercules attaining
this artifact that will basically keep
the Avengers anchored in
modern day despite the fact that their
younger selves have been totally
obliterated what is happening here is he
finds the location of Baden King fights
against you know came to conquer and
scholar centurion when they arrived
as the priests of Palmas location the
priests of promised temple and then of
course we also have the Avengers
arriving on the scene because they're
allowed to be anchored to this amulet
and so think about it this way if the
you know wave of change in the timeline
were actual water the amulet that
percolates is wearing is like throwing a
lifeboat to them it's like throwing you
know a life vest or something like that
if some of the Avengers can hold on to
to keep from being whisked away so the
fact remains here at this point it's
really just kind of dim facing off
against these different versions of
khang and we don't really need to get
super in-depth there because what I end
up doing is making these a bit more
confusing than they need to be but it's
basically them just kind of fighting
against King here and there but what is
up happening is vision basically goes to
Nadia PIM again who's currently lost in
Marvel Comics and stably says your job
is to take this little version of tang
and send it back to where it's supposed
to be the mistake that I made was
removing it from its current universe
removing it from its opponents time you
have to set things back to the later
supposed to be and so of course that's
really just her mission and at this
point it's just the Avengers facing off
against these different verses of khang
and that's really about it I mean
there's there's not a whole lot to go on
here it's just them kind of facing off
against Cain the Conqueror and so
because of this you know once she
returns to the modern day when she comes
back to the present what is it happening
is the Avengers sit down and say okay
look the vision took baby cang away it
resulted in these different versions
that came to conquer descending on us in
order to try to get the baby back the
baby is back where it's supposed to be
now came all these differences of khang
want to kill us so we can never do it
again
and so what is it happening here if Sam
Wilson comes up with an idea and Sam
Wilson's idea is to basically travel
along this timestream to these different
caches that came to conquer uses to keep
himself alive and obliterate them in
their entirety so that came to conquer
will simply cease to exist
and so because of that we also are
basically visited by a version of vision
from the future god this is getting
crazy Mark Waid storytelling is
absolutely nuts but what basically ends
up happening here is that this future
version of the vision essentially says
look guys here's where things stand
right now alright what we're going to do
is we're basically going to jump into
this timestream alright we're going to
go to three different locations across
the time
we're going to destroy came to
conquerors weapon cache we're going to
destroy paying the conquerors system for
generating money and then that means
that the other versions of came to
conquer that exists are simply not going
to be able to function they're going to
cease to exist because the methods they
use to keep themselves alive are not
going to be there because of that what
it's going to do is this basically going
to render down all the different
versions of came to conquer to the point
that they simply cease to exist and
there's only ever going to be that one
future of King and so what is up
happening is they say as long as we
achieve this goal as long as we
basically destroy this connection that
King has to the entire time stream then
once it all goes down that version of
Cana conquer will cease to exist because
you won't be able to feed on the time
stream it'll basically be like depriving
you of water or food or something like
that you'll simply starve to death and
so this is exactly what happens they
basically travel to three different
points in time now we all need to go
through all the different locations that
they go to it's just in general three
different points in time and for the
most part they're successful in
destroying all three of these different
points the problem with this is that
what the Avengers don't realize is that
what came to conquer being all the way
at the very end of time it's going to
take a while for this whole thing to
basically catch up what came to conquer
himself and so because of this we afford
him the opportunity with his other
personalities with immortus who's also a
guy who can manipulate time with a
future version of came to conquer who's
become Doctor Doom it allows these
different gods to traverse the timeline
and then go back and stop the Avengers
before they're able to pull all this off
and so what ends up happening is Hank
Pym from the first Avengers team is able
to harness a device that's able to
basically absorb came to conquer
immortus and this version of Doctor Doom
and keep them in stasis basically keep
them hidden away from the rest of the
universe and so what's essentially
happened here is Mark Waid has come
along and said where there are all these
different verses of khang and all these
different things were going on it was
wildly complicated and unnecessarily
convoluted Hank Pym has effectively
saved the universe because what happens
now is all we have right now in the
realm of Marvel Comics
it's baby king that's it baby king
sleeping in his crib and that's all
there is to it there is no future
version of Cain to conquer there's no
immortus none of that stuff it's a way
for Mark way to basically clean all that
out to remove it all from the situation
and to simply say now the future of Cain
to conquer is completely open
no one knows what the future holds for
him no one knows what he will become
have you said that I understand if a lot
of you guys feel like your brain is
melted because of because of what we
went through and there will probably be
a lot of questions so if there are post
them down in the comment section again
Mark Waid makes us a lot more
complicated than a new city I did my
absolute best to make it make sense this
was one of those things where we kind of
had this like set aside the idea
focusing on what the characters are
thinking and feeling and just makes
sense of the events as they're
transpiring because it's the only way to
make this story makes sense otherwise it
would just throw everybody off but if
you guys are new here to come let's
explain and you again feel a bit
confused post your comments down below
hit that sub bun to become part of the
Rob core and drop a like if you enjoyed
this video and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]